there is nothing worse in life than
hotel coffee but you make do in a
desperate situation and another thing I
don't understand about hotel coffee can
I just say this why is it that they give
you an equal number of decaf and regular
coffee packets I don't know because
there there are only about 3 sociopaths
in the whole country who drink decaf and
frankly those people do not need their
depraved desires and instincts catered
to so it's the worst form of like
affirmative action that we have to have
an equal number of decaf and regular
coffee alright hope you guys are having
a great great day so far a couple things
I want to talk about today and we'll
start with this over the past 24 hours
or so we've been we've heard many
stories about what happened inside
borderline Bar and Grill in California
during the shooting that took 11
innocent lives
the stories are harrowing and horrifying
of course but there had been some some
really inspiring glimmers of courage and
heroism that have come out of this and I
want to highlight two of those if you
haven't heard about these a woman by the
name of Taylor whittler was celebrating
her friend's birthday at the bar
and here's what she reported to Good
Morning America this is what happened to
her she said while we while we were all
dog dog piled over at the side there
were multiple men that got on their
knees and pretty much blocked all of us
with their back toward the shooter ready
to take a bullet for any single one of
us and just the just the amount of
people that made sure everyone got out
ok or if they were out they made sure
they went around to every single person
around them and asked them if they were
ok and if they needed a phone to call
their family or just in general any way
that could help it was awesome there was
another story from a woman named
Savannah who said that two men broke the
windows with chairs and then carried her
friend out to safety so we have men
shielding women from bullets we have men
you know breaking windows carrying women
out to safety and this is a incredible
scene amidst all the tragedy and I think
the culture needs to hear about stuff
like this because it's a culture where
we hear so often about toxic masked
masculinity and we hear about men
who are you know awful and evil and
dangerous men are denigrated all the
time it's important to stop and
recognize these kinds of moments when
they happen I think masculinity real
masculinity a heroic true masculinity
saves lives does not take lives it saves
lives now you can easily point out that
the scumbag who did the shooting was
also a man and that's true enough but
there is a con stark contrast here
between the scumbag shooter and these
men who are saving lives and I think
it's worth exploring okay
the shooter is a desperate apathetic
empty soulless coward spraying bullets
at unarmed and innocent people so he was
a man yes biologically according to his
chromosomes according to his Anatomy but
he was devoid of masculinity he was this
was not a masculine man this was not an
expression of masculinity when you go in
and you kill innocent people this was an
empty man a hollow man the men on the
other hand shielding women from bullets
carrying women out to safety and so on
these are men who feel a duty to protect
these are men of action these are these
are courageous men men of strength and
resolve in the face of danger and when I
say that those are real men and the
shooter was not I mean that the shooter
is rejecting his masculinity rejecting
his responsibility as a man whereas the
heroes at the bar are embracing it now
there are people who when you bring this
up they'll say well yeah but anyone
could have done that anyone could have
could have shielded the bullets anyone
could have carried the women out they
didn't have to be men and that's not
entirely true by the way you know most
women would would not be capable of you
know carrying another grown woman to
safety
or would have a difficulty where they're
just you know just physically doing that
so in fact you do need men for those
kinds of jobs you do need men to do that
kind of thing it probably took a man to
to to smash the window with the with the
chair and carry someone to safety but
it's true that we
can be heroes too nobody is denying that
women's women can be heroes but you
notice something here
the people who dismiss the connection
between masculinity and heroic acts
masculinity and courageous acts they
usually have no problem drawing a
connection between masculinity and
depraved acts violent acts I wonder why
that is
many of these people they'll be they'll
be the first to say that well when you
look at all these mass shooters and the
school should there's there's a problem
with men we need to talk about the
problem with men well if that means that
we talk about the problem with men then
why can't we point to these other
examples and and talk about the the good
things about men why is it in our
culture that men have to take ownership
of all the bad things that men do but we
have no ownership over the good thing
that meant things that men do the good
things well anyone could have done that
the bad things oh yeah well that had to
be a man I mean you notice this dynamic
do we do we is this really healthy is
this good for our sons to live in a
culture like this where that's the
attitude notice something else
if you took a story if you look at a
story like take one that I read recently
about a mother who who drowned while
trying to save her child from a brick
tide actually she saved several of our
children from Riptide and then she she
finally drowned herself tragically there
was also story out of China that I read
a few weeks ago and I think there was a
case like this in the USA recently as
well but I couldn't find it when I just
tried to look it up but in China there
was there was a fire in an apartment
building and a mother got her three
children to safety by by throwing
blankets and pillows out of out of the
window onto the ground below and then
throwing her dropping her kids out the
window and then right after she had
saved her last child she passed out from
the smoke and she died in the fire
now these are examples among many other
examples of motherly love okay of strong
feminine motherly love nobody would have
a problem with me saying that right no
if I say this isn't this is what a
mother does this is a real mother this
is a motherly maternal look these are
strong women real women no one would
have
problem with me saying that and nobody
would would if I said that nobody would
respond and say well what about Andrea
Yates Yates rather than save her
children from drowning actually drowned
them herself all five of them in a
bathtub but the point is that the thing
that makes someone like Yates so
horrifying and terrifying is that she is
a mother yet she had no maternal love
within her she had none of that feminine
strength and courage and beauty and
compassion and all of that so she like
the shooter at the bar was an empty
shell of what she was supposed to be and
we all understand that nobody takes
Andrea Yates and says well that that
proves that there's a problem with women
there's a problem with toxic femininity
there's a problem with mothers in
America even though you know I mean
Andrea Yates is a story horrible story
from years ago but you could
unfortunately find the cases you could
find cases all the time of mothers
killing their their children yet nobody
looks at that as well there's a problem
with women we don't do that because we
look at the positive strong examples of
women and we say yes these are these are
women okay this is what our daughters
should be and we need women who do this
right well all I'm saying is that we
could do the same thing for men for the
sake of our sons
and it's okay to point out that there
are things you there are there are
positive and unique aspects and
attributes of men and the reason why we
point those out is so that we can show
those to our sons and to other young men
in America and say you know this be this
do this you'll realize your full
potential
if you do that you know and if we put
that kind of example forward to our to
our sons then maybe you know maybe down
the road we'll have more of the kind of
men who are shielding bullets and fewer
of the sort of men who are shooting them
at innocent people speaking of
masculinity or or or lack thereof um I
want to tell you about about this a male
to female transgender that is a man who
thinks his woman is suing sixteen women
for refusing to wax his male genitalia
okay here's a let me read a little bit
from The Daily wire article on this it
says John carpe who's a lawyer for the
President and the president of the
Justice Center for constitutional
freedoms he's representing two of the
women who are being targeted by the
complainant the complainant referred to
only as jy in now he's he's referred to
only as jy he's anonymous in accordance
with an order from the BC Human Rights
Tribunal so he gets to be anonymous but
the women are named anyway the lawyer
says in recent months jy approached 16
Vancouver area female esta estheticians
s is that what the we'll just call them
wax ologist I guess for simplicity he
approached 16 wax ologists who only
serve women requesting a Brazilian
bikini wax on his groin area in spite of
the fact that jy is able to maintain
obtain a man zillion in Vancouver as
well jy has filed 16 complaints against
these women at the BC Human Rights
Tribunal claiming discrimination on the
basis of gender identity the female wax
ologists in question only serve women
and do not offer so-called man xilians
which is the man the male equivalent to
a brazilian wax guy just pause here for
a minute because I find this this is
annoying to me where we we put man in
front of things to specify that it's
something that a man is doing when it
doesn't make sense because Brazilian
okay bra doesn't mean women it's just
shouldn't be man brazilian why do we
need it
it just man
don't need to you don't need to sub out
bra for man because it could apply to
either men or women couldn't it anyway
the procedure for providing a man with a
man's iliyan is quite different using a
different kind of wax and a different
technique noted the lawyer
Sheila ploy her one of the women carpe
is defending against jy pro bono as a
single mother works out of her home so
we should give credit to this lawyer by
the ways doing this pro bono for these
women or one of the women anyway and the
story goes on from there apparently the
man dropped one of the complaints that
he that he had made against one of the
women when he saw that the woman was
going to defend himself and had procured
a lawyer but he's also said that he will
drop all of the complaints if he's given
twenty five hundred dollars from each of
the women he wants twenty five hundred
dollars a piece and then he'll drop all
the complaints so just to be clear about
this okay let's do just to clear about
what's happening here this is a man
demanding that women pay him for the
rights to not touch his genitals I want
to say that again okay I don't want to
say it again but I will this is a man
demanding that women pay him for the
right to not touch his genitals side
note I'm in a hotel right now and the
walls are very thin and I can hear
somebody on the other side of those
walls so they're I don't know what how
much of this they're picking up but
they're probably very confused if
there's someone in the other room
shouting about genital waxes he probably
imagines that I'm on the phones the only
here's one side of the conversation so
he probably thinks I'm on the phone
right now
shouting to somebody about about male
genital waxes so we'll just we'll let
him whoever that is though they can
wonder about that mystery now here's my
question is the same question I always
have with this stuff where are the
feminists on this what you shouldn't
every feminist be up in arms about
something like this where you have you
have men intruding into in you know we
already have men intruding into into
female spaces into locker rooms and
baths
everything and now it's gotten to the
point where you have a man demanding
that a woman touch his intimate areas
what's the difference between this and
what like Harvey Weinstein did what's
the difference between this guy this
quote transgender and Harvey Weinstein
Harvey Weinstein used his the power of
his position used his influence to
compel women to engage in in sexual
activities with him whereas this man is
using his status as a victim he's using
his protected status and he's using the
authority of the government and the
courts to compel women to touch him
intimately what is the difference
between those two things I I can't think
of how we draw any distinction between
them so if the feminists are really
going to to fight the me to fight and if
they're gonna be consistent about it
then they should be standing up and and
saying something about these kinds of
things this is this is why feminism is
so useless these days because the the
fights that they should be fighting
where we actually need them they say
nothing because they're afraid they've
been cowed into silence by the LGBT
lobby what I'm saying to feminists is is
have some courage stand up don't let
these don't let the LGBT lobby boss you
around bully you don't sit don't don't
forfeit everything that you you pretend
to want and pretend to fight for just
because they're making demands I mean
the most of the legal and fights and
most of the fights for women's rights
those fights are in the past now those
struggles are in the past most of that
has been done it's been won women have
the right to vote they have all the same
they have most of the same legal rights
as men but this is one particular area
where women I I think are being legally
persecuted this is the legal persecution
of women when men are able to use the
power of the courts and the power of the
government to compel
to do this or to order or to tolerate
men coming into their locker rooms that
is legal persecution of women and that
is where feminists should be standing up
and saying something
where are the feminists on that they're
there they're off you know complaining
about manspreading
or something they're complaining about
men having they're having their with
with with you know spreading their legs
too much on the subway well what about
this what why is it by the way why is it
let's just ask ourselves this guy
why is he and why why why must he insist
that women be the one to perform this
procedure on him if he really feels for
some god-awful reason if he feels the
need to have that part of his body waxed
well then fine there's a place where he
can go where men will do it there's a
place that specializes in doing that for
men and now I I don't wanna get into the
Nitty Gritty here IIIi don't know how a
place that specializes in that doing
that for men could possibly stay over
there that meant well anyway look the
fact is that place exists but know this
guy insists he wants women to do it why
is that I mean we can only speculate
we're left only to speculate is this on
his part some kind of like sexual thing
where he gets some sort of sexual
fulfillment from from having women do I
don't know we as I said we could only
speculate and and when you're a man
making these kinds of demands and being
a bully like this then you will you
leave yourself open to speculation and
this is bullying okay I don't I know
there are people who who think well you
know yeah this stuff is crazy but
obviously these people are mentally ill
so we should we should you know we
should be compassionate we should have
sympathy and I do have compassion I do
have sympathy and I in this is mental
illness and this guy obviously is
mentally ill and for that aspect of the
probably of the situation for his
psychological problems I do have
sympathy but when you take the
step to try to force women into touching
you well that is no that's that's not
mental illness that's just you being a
bully that is that is just evil that's
you being a bad person you're just a bad
person
I don't care transgender or whatever it
doesn't matter what your gender identity
is when you when you do that you're just
a bad horrible awful person and you
should be ashamed of yourself I mean
what if what if this guy actually
succeeded in in coercing or extorting
these women into performing this thing
on him is that really what he wants the
does he want these humiliated
uncomfortable embarrassed women to be
forced to do that is that really what he
wants yeah well it is apparently what he
wants because he's just a bad person and
he is exactly the sort of bully that
feminists ought to be fighting against
not only has the appropriated womanhood
and made a mockery and a cartoon out of
it but now he is not having no respect
at all for the autonomy of women and for
their right to to to to just to consent
we've made such a mockery of human
rights at the the the whole idea of
human rights we've made such a mockery
of it which is really a shame because
our entire civilization is built on the
foundation on the basis of human rights
and of the respect of human rights but
what are human rights
if now we're saying that you have the
human right to have your genitals waxed
by a woman okay if if if that's a human
right then I don't know what isn't a
human right at that point if that
qualifies as a human right then I don't
know what couldn't qualify we have taken
the
idea of Rights and we have completely at
this point conflated it with desire
where now the two ideas are basically
interchangeable where someone says I
have a right to this it's the same thing
as them saying I want to do this and
there's no way for us to tell the
difference anymore so it's time to stand
up against this bullying and because you
know enough is enough that a certain
point all right we'll leave it on that
somewhat disturbing note and have a
great weekend everybody talk to you next
week
Godspeed